[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] I
convey my message to the world, the message of the children of Palestine,
that we promote creativity through music.
What about the Sununo Institute has actually added something big
to your life? Because for a long time it was my dream to join
an institute that would care about me, so I found the Sununo Institute and I am
actually interested in it, I mean, to a degree.  Great, especially. I mean,
he taught me the oud
[applause]
in the Gaza Strip, because we are suffering from the siege. The
best way, because we face this thing, is through
music. We use all our energy. Music and
singing, in general, really helped me a
lot in my life. I got to know a lot of my friends at the institute. I talked to them and we
got to know each one’s place.  I bring the
instrument, I follow it, and I go down,
and actually, I mean, it was a big thing in my life. We as a
Palestinian people, as a besieged people,
as a people under siege. We want to deliver talents. We have children. We have children. We have people who live here. [Music] [Music] Our message from the music is that the children of Gaza deserve to
live. Support them through...  Music in peace is a
project that came to you as a response to special needs
and lesser needs related to psychological release,
especially after the psychological pressures and traumas
that they were exposed to after the war.
It helps that we are communicating in a way that the
whole world knows, which is the way of sheep, which is
global communication, and it is in fact that we are going to
continue our voice through our popular songs through
movements.  Dabkeh, things like this, we
deliver to the world and our culture that there is still the
people of Palestine, our name is Palestine
[music]